there were a number of stories going
around a couple days ago about Alex
Jones's conspiracy and propaganda news
website Infowars announcing that it had
been granted press credentials that
would allow it to cover the White House
press briefing specifically Washington
bureau chief of Infowars Infowars jerome
corsi who is a top-level Swift boater
birther conspiracy theorist that he
would be attending White House press
briefings but then almost immediately
counter reporting came out saying you
know what Infowars didn't get a
permanent White House press credential
here they got a temporary one day pass
for Jerome Corsi this is something that
like a high school newspaper can get
here's a tweet from Mike Warren of the
Weekly Standard who said regarding
Jerome Corsi and Infowars I saw his pass
it's a temporary pass almost anyone who
publishes can get they even gave it to
me I guess that that should make us feel
slightly feel make us feel slightly
better because Alex Jones is someone who
has accused the US government of being
involved in the Oklahoma City bombing in
1995 in the 9/11 terrorist attacks he
has talked about the moon landings being
faked he's talked about the government
faking the Sandy Hook school shooting
using crisis actors and almost
immediately after jerome corsi got what
might be a one day or permanent pass for
the White House press briefing room
wasting no time at all Alex Jones took
to smearing the victims of the
Manchester England
Ariana Grande terrorist attack as quote
liberal trendies take a listen to this
in less than 24 hours after President
Trump finishes that speech a big bomb
goes off at a pop stars rock concert
bombing a bunch of liberal trendies the
same people God loved them on average
who are promoting open borders bringing
Islam assist in Trump's been blocking
that and saying you don't come here from
unvetted countries and Saudi Arabia many
elements of their government there's
different factions but they've been
caught funding Isis and al Qaeda
Krum has already defeated those armies
in Syria later in this bizarre video
Alex Jones again slams the victims not
the perpetrator the victims of this
horrible
whether it's the government whether it's
the king doing it the big issue here the
thing we have to focus on and face is
that this is what's coming out of Saudi
Arabia one way or the other and this is
the response a day later
is to blow up a bunch of trendies who've
already run a white flag up to the black
flag of Wahhabism a bunch of liberals
who've already run up the white flag to
the Islamists and this happens so more
of our liberties can be loss and so
governments in Europe the UK and the
u.s. can say don't criticize Muslims or
they'll blow you up because there's the
religion of P Howard the eight-year-old
girl who is killed at that horrible
bombing and other kids part of the
problem that Alex Jones is describing
here and if indeed it's not true and it
I hope that it is not true that Infowars
has gotten a permanent credential to
White House press briefings that would
be the Trump era right this this
Breitbart is a credentialed White House
press briefing media outlets and once
you go to Breitbart whether or not this
was a one day pass or a permanent pass
that Infowars got it's not that much
further from Breitbart to Infowars well
you know Alex Jones has had to apologize
for a lot lately he had to apologize for
damaging the reputation of James
elephanta sand comet ping-pong with the
whole pizza gate thing yeah then he had
to apologize to Chobani yogurt for
saying that they support migrant rapists
yeah so I think his new role is just
being apologists for the horrid actions
of the Trump administration yeah that
that's that that would be effectively
the new thing that he would be doing and
I've told the story before and this is a
good time to mention it because during a
recent child custody hearing Alex
Jones's lawyer said you can't use
anything that Alex Jones says on his
show to show that he's an unfit parent
because he's a quote performance artist
in other words he's sort of playing a
character now Alex Jones denied that but
I've told the story before a few years
ago at the talkers new media seminar in
New York City I was in a really really
small group of having a conversation
with Alex Jones it was me Alex Jones and
then the two hosts a free talk live mark
edge and Ian Freeman and I didn't know
Alex Jones right so I was really talking
to mark and Ian and they knew Alex Jones
and Alex Jones shows up after his
keynote address that he gave at this
radio seminar
and it was abundantly clear that number
one he alluded to the idea that he can
decide whether to turn it on or turn it
off he said something like I thought
about really freaking him out but I
decided not to sort of like he did a
totally straight ahead speech about
online video monetization and and
podcast ads and stuff like that but just
in spending ten minutes with the guy and
I guarantee you if you ask him about
this he would not remember my presence
there okay I mean this was like seven
years ago and the guy didn't say a word
to me I was I was just happen to be
standing there when he walked up there
was nothing in common between the Alex
Jones on screen and the Alex Jones that
I saw so I actually do believe that the
guy is just a character well maybe I
mean it's been a bad few months for him
now with that performance artist thing
coming out and yeah with all these
apologies so I guess the White House
press credentials even if it's just for
a day is so a good sign for him yeah
it's something that he can say points to
legitimacy when in fact it's just as
we've talked about propaganda news